New technologies have allowed us to really
rethink education as a journey
rather than an event.
And the new lead certificate is gonna
provide an opportunity for
executives to engage in deep and
meaningful social interaction,
while at the same time consume education
at the pace that's appropriate for them.
[MUSIC]
The Stanford LEAD Certificate in corporate
innovation will provide you
with the strategic business tools and
techniques to drive change and
transformation within your organization.
We design this program for people who
wanna learn on the job,
with the support of the Stanford faculty,
and a community of colleagues.
[MUSIC]
The format is designed to be flexible.
So that you could really, engage with the
concepts.
Understand how they could be applied and
allow you to start transforming your
organization, while you're in the program.
[MUSIC]
You're gonna have the opportunity to
interact with Stanford faculty,
Silicone Valley leaders, coaches, together
with your peers in the program.
We have a rich set of elective courses.
[MUSIC]
All led by the best faculty from the
Stanford GSB and the university overall.
They will have the opportunity to watch
self paced video lectures,
exchange ideas and collaborate in team
based projects.
Engage in class wide discussions, receive
ongoing peer and faculty feedback.
The participants will interact as team,
sharing problems that have come from their
own business experiences.
Using that to help their colleagues in the
program,
through the challenges that they're facing
within their organizations.
And each course in the program will have
multiple opportunities for
live interaction with the faculty.
[MUSIC]
Stanford GSB is located in the heart of
Silicon Valley,
one of the most dynamic and innovative
places in the entire world.
And there's a unique mindset here the
faculty are highly engaged in
thinking through how to translate their
material into this online environment and
we're really going to be doing something
special in this program.
We're really excited about the depth and
the rigor that we're gonna be able to
put into this program, that's one of the
reasons why we've decided to give
participants the LEAD certificate at the
conclusion of this program.
Cuz they can use to document, their
experience, and
the expertise that they're going to take
away.
[MUSIC]
This is not a MOOC or a massive online
course.
This is really a way of immersing yourself
in the Stanford community, and
this is designed to be a highly selective
program open to
high potential individuals around the
globe.
Who are ready to engage and
collaborate with a small community of
others live themselves,
as well as the Stanford faculty in a
highly engaging online format.
[MUSIC]
It's flexible, collaborative, at your own
pace, on your own turf, and
designed to meet the business challenges
that you're facing in your organization.
[MUSIC]